[Musik]
viktor orban kämpft um die macht
gewinnen wir die wichtigste schlacht
unseres lebens
im system orban ist alles darauf
ausgerichtet presse wirtschaft
rechtsstaat
machtapparat
sie haben es die liberal autoritär
hybridsystem oder gott weiß wie genannt
sein herausforderer sieht das so in
diesem mafia staat geht es um macht
wir wollen wissen wie das system aber
das leben der menschen verändert wir
sehen der widerstand wächst
auch aus europa
sie führen einen dschihad gegen uns
plötzlich krieg im nachbarland ukraine
putin freund orban unter druck wird sein
system das überstehen
[Musik]
der krieg ändert alte gewissheiten
ungarn nimmt nun flüchtlinge auf
früher machte orban wahlkampf gegen
sogenannte migranten nun zeigen ihn
seine facebook videos wie er sie
freundlich begrüßt
es ist die erste flucht erfahrung für
menschen in not hier in budapest es gibt
ihnen eine chance auf eine glücklichere
zukunft
es sei nachbarschaftshilfe so die
botschaft und sie überlagert eine nähe
zu russland die orban vor dem krieg
pflegt zum eigenen machterhalt
[Musik]
wir sind an der grenze zur ukraine
ungarn liegt auf der schwelle zwischen
ost und west hier sind sie in sicherheit
hier beginnt die eu hier endet die
russische welt der eisenbahn
von der russischen spurbreite auf die
mitteleuropäische umzuladen ist im
frieden ein geschäft mit riesenpotenzial
infineon schließt entsteht ein neues
umschlagterminals teil der neuen
seidenstraße
das sei orban zu verdanken meint
bürgermeister mihai tv markt und seinen
guten beziehungen zu russland und china
warum gibt ein volk einem bestimmten
menschen diese macht
damit er schlauer ist und seinem land in
der wirtschaft politik und allgemein und
der weltpolitik vorteile verschafft
das ist überall so auch bei ihnen
mit mastermind orban sei gut für ungarn
und für sein dorf
wir besuchen ihnen kurz vor dem ukraine
krieg
langfristig sollen hier hunderte
container aus china umgeladen werden
hofft er
es ist das millionen investment eines
russisch stämmigen investors mit
ungarischen pass
nur eines von vielen projekten mit
russland connection
ein joint venture mit russischer
beteiligung wird hier weitere milliarden
in schienen stecken
ungarn kauft mit einem russischen zehn
milliarden kredit russische atom
technologie
die russische investmentbank in budapest
genießt diplomatische sonderrechte putin
liefert impfstoffe und stellte band kurz
vor dem krieg mehr gas zu billigeren
preisen in aussicht die länder sind eng
verflochten das zeigen auch die fahnen
opern gehört zu den bremsern bei
eu-sanktionen
ungarn würden energie sanktionen
unverhältnismäßig belastet da ungarn 85
prozent seines gases aus russland
bezieht
auch deutschland zögert aber ungebremst
mehr der außenminister und träger des
russischen freundschaftsorden schließt
ungarische hilfe für die ukraine aus
wir haben entschieden keine truppen und
keine waffen zu schätzen und
wir erlauben auch keine tödlichen waffen
über ungarischen territorien
denn sie könnten das ziel feindlicher
militärische reaktionen werden
finja schlitte an der grenze ist ein
bisschen wie ganz und es liegt zwischen
ost und west und will von beiden
profitieren so sollen gute zeiten für
alle anbrechen
und der bürgermeister ist ein bisschen
wie orban stolz auf unsere traditionen
zeigt er mir die kirche aus dem 13
jahrhundert
hier seien alle christlich und patrioten
natürlich wähle man rechts nur
habenichtse welten links und die gäbe es
hier kaum erklärte mir er gibt den guten
patriarchen sowie orban für das ganze
land
die ungarische gesellschaft wie auch für
andere mittel osteuropäische länder ist
die familie sehr wichtig dass familien
förderungsprogramm der regierung wird
von allen als sehr gut bewertet genau
das stärkt speziell orban in dieser wahl
im kindergarten von kenia schnitker ist
noch platz junge paare haben wenig
nachwuchs und wandern ab
der bürgermeister ist deshalb froh dass
die regierung orban im wahljahr die
förderung kinderreicher familien noch
mal erhöht hat
der kampf um kinder wird auch
ideologisch geführt kinderbücher in
denen schwule oder lesben vorkommen
gelten nun als nicht jugendfragen das
sei menschenrechtswidrig sagt die eu
wir sind in der eu eine große familie
die familie unterschiedlicher nation auf
meine familie runtergebrochen heißt das
ich habe drei kinder sie haben drei
verschiedene interessen sie haben andere
vorstellungen von der welt wir haben
auch mal streit aber wir bleiben eine
familie und bemühen uns zusammen zu
bleiben
keinesfalls will ungarn die eu verlassen
sagt er nicht zuletzt wegen der vielen
subventionen
doch die eu will manche nicht mehr
auszahlen zu oft sei korruption im spiel
so auch bei der erneuerung der
bahnlinien bei phoenix
es sind immer die gleichen wenigen leute
die in ungarn das große geschäft machen
der bürgermeister weiter weg
wenn ich drei kilogramm tomaten kaufe
dann werde ich nicht nach der
vergangenheit des verkäufers fragen oder
wo er herkommt das ist nicht meine
aufgabe dafür gibt es ja politik und
ausschüsse gegen korruption damit sie so
etwas ans licht bringen das ist zu groß
für mich
der horizont des bürgermeisters ist
begrenzt und auch darauf stützt sich das
system aber
auf ihn ist alles ausgerichtet die eu
soll sich besser heraushalten gern nimmt
er ihr geld ungern ihre verpflichtungen
wegen mängeln bei rechtsstaatlichkeit
werden aber nun eu gelder nicht
ausgezahlt
die kommission spielt ein politisches
match man sieht doch dass es darauf
hinausläuft die ungarische regierung zu
schwächen dahinter steckt das ziel dass
es nach den wahlen nicht mehr diese
regierung gibt
kein interview vom ungarischen
außenminister zu diesen fragen auch die
eu kommission hält sich lieber zurück
kein interview aber das europäische
parlament lässt ungarn keine ruhe daniel
freund und andere parlamentarier waren
erst kürzlich wieder in ungarn
erwärmt die eu-subventionen
stabilisieren das system orban und in
großem stil werden diese eu gelder von
orban und seinem umfeld geklaut das geld
wird in großem stile zu machterhalt
benutzt und um sich selbst zu bereichern
so war es auch hier tatort gut mädel war
haye
[Musik]
corpus delicti die straßenlaternen teure
aber ungeeignete 15 größtenteils von der
eu bezahlt das geld landete in den
taschen von orban schwiegersohn am ende
flog die sache auf und die bürger werden
einen oppositions man ins rathaus dieser
neue bürgermeister will das system orban
nun im ganzen land besiegen
darum geht's bei korruptions in diesem
mafia staat geht es um macht orban will
macht loyalität und volle kontrolle
hier in der booster ist die heimat von
peter markise spitzenkandidat der
vereinten opposition
[Musik]
er vertritt die sechs wichtigsten
oppositionsparteien von links bis rechts
ein mühsamer wahlkampf peter marke soll
schüttet jede einzelne hand rund 30
anhänger sind ins kulturhaus von martin
gekommen
[Musik]
ungarn war nie so korrupt wie heute in
unserer 1000-jährigen geschichte hatten
wir nie so eine korrupte regierung
die armut der ungarn der reichtum von
orbáns freunden das ist sein thema und
damit findet er gehör denn hier auf dem
land haben die meisten leute wenig geld
unsere vier enkel sind im ausland
geboren die eltern haben das land
verlassen
mein sohn ist lehrer als er sein erstes
gehalt bekam kaufte er ein t shirt eine
jeans eine monatskarte und dann war sein
geld alles
markise ist hier der lokalmatador ein
rechtsliberale
wirtschaftswissenschaftler der was von
der welt gesehen hat vater von sieben
kindern in dieser kirche besucht der
strenggläubige katholik den gottesdienst
ungarn gehöre zu den ärmsten ländern in
der eu und das sei untragbar doch wie er
ungarn wieder erfolgreich machen will
erfahren die meisten ungarn nicht und
das liegt an organs medienmacht
dies ist der einzige auftritt den ihm
das ungarische staatsfernsehen gewährt 5
[Musik]
vielen dank dass die opposition hier in
vier jahren fünf minuten reden darf so
wie man hier über mich berichtet
erkennen mich meine kinder und die
bürger von hesl war schnell nicht wieder
was sie verschweigen den leuten die
wahrheit
urbans medien senden vor allem orban
mitten in huttwil war steht heute ein
junger mann der eilt das ändern will
martin gollasch aktivist journalist und
der erfolgreichste politische influenza
des landes
[Musik]
mit diesem mobilen studio sind wir die
kommenden wochen unterwegs
bei ihm bekommt die opposition ein forum
das sie im system orban nicht hat
[Musik]
ich habe frust aber ich habe auch diese
chance dieses mittel diesem weg um
meinen frust in etwas zu verwandeln das
für hunderttausende ungarn wichtig und
interessant
einen wm marathon hat man in ungarn noch
nicht gesehen als außerirdischer
bösewicht versuchte er einmal eine
aufenthaltserlaubnis bei den behörden zu
erwirken eine persiflage auf baumanns
migrationspolitik
mit solchen videos versucht er das
system orban zu entlarven
[Musik]
ich mache euch zu stolzen ungarn das ist
obamas strategie ich mache euch nicht zu
reichen nicht zu gesunden aber zu
stolzen ungarn
und die leute sagen klingt gut so machen
wir das denn sie glauben nicht dass
politiker ihnen wohlstand bildung oder
gesundheit bieten können
seit jahren versucht orban seine macht
systematisch zu sichern
2011 ist der moment der marathons
politischen kampfgeist weckt da hatte
das system orban ein neues wahlgesetz
eingeführt das die fidesz-partei auch
durch überhangmandate bei wahlen
bevorteilt
[Musik]
das führte dazu dass orban 2018 mit 49
prozent der stimmen eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im parlament bekam
nach der letzten wahl war völlig klar
die opposition muss sich vereinen denn
sonst ist es für sie unmöglich bei der
wahl mit der regierung gleichzuziehen
[Musik]
marton gulasch gehörte zu den ersten die
forderten dass die opposition gemeinsam
antreten muss von ganz links bis ganz
rechts für den kandidaten markise ist
das jedoch ein politischer drahtseilakt
ich gebe da die richtung vor
wir teilen vier grundwerte demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit marktwirtschaft und
europäische integration
diese koalition wird ein albtraum aber
ich habe noch einen größeren raum in der
ist dass orban dieses land weitere
die botschaft der opposition orban
handlanger von putin verräter
ungarischer interessen
markise reist sogar nach berlin und
versichert der deutschen politik mit ihm
kehre ungarn in die reihe überzeugte
europäer und nato mitglieder zurück
sichert das bekenntnis zum westen einen
wahlerfolg
wegen des krieges in der ukraine hat es
mark ii soll schwer mit seinen
botschaften durchzudringen in budapest
der hochburg der opposition kann er
dennoch zehntausende mobilisieren
es gibt nur eine gute wahl wir müssen
nicht den osten wählen sondern europa
war es
doch gegen das system ordern anzukommen
ist in ungarn schwer
es wäre ein wunder wenn wir gewinnen es
wäre das achte weltwunder
um wähler wie ihn wird markise jung
urban gut ausgebildet ist waren
korridors lebt wegen der arbeit in
berlin ist aber noch in budapest
gemeldet knapp 200.000 ungarn leben so
in deutschland rund 500.000 in
westeuropa viele würden gegen orban
stimmen wenn es für sie nicht so schwer
wäre es gibt nur fünf möglichkeiten in
deutschland berlin dortmund stuttgart
nürnberg und münchen
so für mich ist ein ziemlich einfacher
weil ich wohne in berlin aber die die
leute die zum beispiel in hamburg wo sie
sollen auch eine extra reise für die
wahlen machen und dann oft an stehen
stundenlang hier bilder aus london
viele konnten an diesem tag ihre stimme
gar nicht abgeben
ich war und seine freunde wollen
trotzdem mobilisieren für markisen
nämlich
für diese wähler kommt er extra nach
berlin
es sei teil des systems orban dass den
liberalen ungarn im westen das wählen
schwer gemacht wird
unsere regierung macht einen
riesenunterschied zwischen den auslands
ungarn im osten und denen im westen wie
hier in deutschland
den auslandsungarn im osten können per
brief abstimmen
die sportart und bot dort liegen im
osten nahe der grenze
es ist ungarns ärmste region
[Musik]
orbáns fidesz gewann hier die meisten
stimmen ein grund rechtzeitig zu wahlen
gibt wohl 1000 keine einkommenssteuer
mehr für unter 25-jährige und für die
alten bio lanka eine dreizehnte
monatsrente ich würde nur orbáns fidesz
wählen
ein weiterer grund für den fidesz
wahlerfolg die östlichen auslands ungarn
kurz vor kriegsausbruch sind wir hier es
fliegen schon die ersten ukraine wir
treffen konnten
ungarische ukraine
so sagt sie habe ihr die
doppelstaatsbürgerschaft ermöglicht eine
ungarische rente ein wahlrecht in ungarn
man wähle ich natürlich er hat den zweit
pass möglich gemacht und unterstützt uns
seit obamas machtantritt wurden rund 1,2
millionen pässe an auslands ungarn
ausgegeben neue treue staatsbürger für
europa ans system
[Musik]
glauben sie dass sie die einzige doppel
staatsbürgerin sind die für orban stimmt
oder das alles
er hat uns die pässe gegeben mit denen
können wir problemlos die grenze
überqueren ohne das wäre das nicht
möglich
diesen wählern hat die orban regierung
viel zu verdanken sagt der vize premier
und die 2014 und 18 haben wir mit den
stimmen unseres ungarischen blutes
außerhalb der grenzen die zwei drittel
mehrheit erreicht
[Applaus]
auch weil in der gegend alle
direktkandidaten von fidesz gewonnen wie
werden eigentlich ausschließlich von
bürgern gewählt die tatsächlich hier
wohnen
[Musik]
doch zu den wahlen zogen plötzlich viele
ukraine her sie wohnten angeblich in
solchen ruinen oder zu dutzenden in
einfamilienhäusern in diesem zum
beispiel aber adam schank der hier wohnt
hat sie nie gesehen
er erzählt wie er von seinen rund 130
ausländischen mitbewohnern erfuhr
die damalige fidesz bürgermeisterin hat
die anmeldungen in der ukraine
arrangiert ohne unser wissen
sie hat nun später gesagt dass sie diese
leute in unserem haus angemeldet hat wir
sollen die formulare unterschreiten im
gegenzug versprach sie arbeit in der
gemeinde
hat einen job anderswo und deshalb ist
der frei genug über das system zu
sprechen
in cash polat war 2009 10 einer der
letzten freien tv sender rtl klub dabei
während ukraine abstimmen stehen kanada
daneben
es interessiert sie nicht sie kommen
wählen und gehen wieder und wissen nicht
was hier weiter passiert
bei den letzten parlamentswahlen sei es
auch so gelaufen doppelstaatsbürger mit
ungarischen scheinadressen stimmten für
direktkandidaten das war damals illegal
[Musik]
bei den parlamentswahlen war ich als
delegierter eine oppositionspartei dabei
und die doppelten staatsbürger kamen
massenweise wäre ich meine das damals
mehr doppelstaatsbürger gewählt haben
als ungarn die tatsächliche
die bürgermeisterin wurde wegen
urkundenfälschung in erster instanz
verurteilt aber adam und sein nachbar
kálmán fühlen sich trotzdem als
verlierer
jetzt hat orban das gesetz verändert man
muss hier nicht mehr leben und wohnen um
direktkandidaten wählen zu können das
ist die korruption die er macht nicht
die bürgermeister machen dass sondern
der ungarische ministerpräsident
wir sind empört weil die order partei
fidesz das gesetz modifiziert hat
so wollen sie
2022 die wahlen gewinnen
so wollen sie wieder eine
zweidrittelmehrheit hohen
wir bemühen uns im bürgermeisteramt um
stellungnahme persönlich und auch
schriftlich keine reaktion
wir bemühen uns auch mehrfach in der
hauptstadt um ein interview mit der
regierung bis redaktionsschluss bekommen
wir nur absagen
mit der zweidrittelmehrheit im parlament
kann orban die verfassung ändern er tut
es bis hin zur menschenrechtsverletzung
theaterabend in budaörs heute steht
freude und glück auf dem spielplan
die ungarn gehen sehr gerne ins theater
das stück das sie heute sehen ist in
ungarn nicht jugendfrei und das liegt an
dieser szene
[Musik]
weil in diesem stück ein schwuler junger
mann vor kommt darf es jugendlichen
nicht gezeigt werden so bestimmt es ein
orban gesetz das sogenannte homosexuelle
propaganda verbieten soll laut
eu-kommission ist das gesetz
menschenrechtswidrig
wir treffen den regisseur des stückes
robert wolfe die einer der berühmtesten
theatermacher ungarns
dieses gesetz ist eine perfekte
marketing kampagne
es geht aber nicht nur um die wahl
es geht nicht um den schutz der kinder
nicht um sexuelle aufklärung und nicht
um christliche werte es ist einfach
marketing es geht darum ein feindbild zu
schaffen jemanden zu hassen
das stück spielt in der ungarischen
minderheit in rumänien und versucht zu
ergründen wie diese ungarische
minderheit mit ihrer eigenen minderheit
um geht nämlich mit den homosexuellen
wenn man nicht darüber redet dann gibt
es das auch nicht so ist dass
demokratie offenheit akzeptanz
solidarität das muss eine gesellschaft
lernen
dieses stück wird in einem kleinen
unabhängigen theater gespielt auf einer
staatlichen bühne wäre es nicht möglich
denn das system bahn definiert genau wie
familien in ungarn aussehen und
dargestellt werden müssen
der vater ist ein mann die mutter ist
eine frau und lasst unsere kinder in
frieden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich besuche esther und christina bei
denen ist die mama eine frau die zweite
mama auch eine frau und das kind der
kleine daniel
wir haben zwei warte mama und mutti
ich bin die mama und christina ist die
mutter tanja
im dezember haben wir unsere
partnerschaft eintragen lassen
christina ist jetzt offiziell
stiefmutter unseres sohnes
das gibt uns eine gewisse sicherheit
ich glaube wir sind eine ganz normale
familie
für kinder ist es selbstverständlich
dass sie um sich herum sehen daniel weiß
dass es kinder gibt die zwei meter haben
eine mutter und einen vater oder nur ein
elternteil das war mal thema aber jetzt
interessiert es ihn nicht mehr
dass wir diese familie überhaupt zeigen
können ist eine absolute ausnahme keine
andere regenbogenfamilie hat sich das
getraut anwälte raten ihnen davon ab zu
groß die angst vor organs propaganda
gesetz und gesellschaftlichen
repressionen
was bedeutet es wenn in den medien in
der schule im theater oder in büchern
homosexualität nicht mehr genannt werden
darf sobald jugendliche in der nähe sind
[Musik]
es sind vor allem jugendliche die jetzt
in einem umfeld aufwachsen müssen in dem
sie spüren wenn sie nicht heterosexuell
sind müssen sie ihre gefühle
verheimlichen weil die regierung die
medien und manchmal sogar die eigene
familie gegen sie ist das ist sehr
schädlich
urbans gesetz gegen die verbreitung
homosexueller inhalte hat europaweit für
große aufregung gesorgt
aus protest leuchtete die allianz arena
während der fußball europameisterschaft
in den regenbogenfarben und der deutsche
kapitän manuel neuer trug demonstrativ
eine regenbogen binde
homosexuelle zu feinden zu erklären so
orban im wahlkampf stimmen sichern das
besorgt auch die aktivistin jarvis
seufzen
die situation von lg bietet menschen in
ungarn ist sehr schlecht sehr viele
bekannte und freunde von mir wollen
deshalb ins ausland ziehen
die lesbenorganisation von jörg fischer
hat ein kinderbuch herausgebracht in dem
geschichten geht es darum dass manche
ein bisschen anders sind menschen mit
behinderung menschen mit wenig geld und
auch zwei prinzen heiraten
das buch ist in ungarn als
jugendgefährdend eingestuft
das bedeutet dass buchläden in denen es
verkauft wird solche schilder an der tür
anbringen müssen auf denen steht dass
hier nicht traditionelle inhalte
verkauft werden
solche bilder wie das system orban nicht
solche bilder dagegen schon ein
männlicher mann der ein schwein
geschlachtet und dann einen schnaps
trinkt
so inszeniert er einen kulturkampf um
ein angeblich echtes ungarn tun das nur
einen zweck gedient teile und herrsche
wir die heteros sie die homosexuelle
die christen sie die migranten
es scheint dass die ungarn dafür
empfänglich sind
wir lieben herrscher mit starker hand
die uns vor dem fremden beschützen das
ist die politik orban
das hat leider hats und spaltung in die
familien gebracht
doch im sommer
2021 zeigte sich dass sich die
gesellschaft von orban nicht alles
bieten lassen will es ist der bis dahin
größte protest für sexuelle vielfalt in
der geschichte ungarns
wir sehen solidarität und das ist gut
plötzlich kam ein junger mann auf mich
zu er sagte ich bin hetero aber dieses
gesetz hat mich auch aufgeregt und ich
denke dass mein platz jetzt neben euch
ist
viele sind empört darüber was die
regierung mit den homosexuellen macht
und deshalb waren viele unterstützer
darin
bat
die familie von esther versucht weiter
ein normales leben zu führen
ich möchte dass wir versuchen uns
gegenseitig zu akzeptieren
und dass die politik die minderheiten in
ruhe lässt ich will einfach in frieden
leben
doch das system orban lässt jene nicht
in ruhe die anders denken
drei jahre war dies der weg zur arbeit
für gabriela szo
viele jahre hatte sie daraufhin
gearbeitet am verwaltungsgericht
budapest recht sprechen zu dürfen sie
ist richterin mit leib und seele
doch nach einer art probezeit wurde sie
im amt nicht bestätigt
für drei jahre war die das gericht mein
leben alles war ihm untergeordnet es ist
ein schlechtes gefühl hier zu stehen und
zu wissen dass ich keine richterin bin
ich kann nicht verstehen was ich falsch
gemacht habe
sie betrat vermintes gelände politisch
gesehen
die regierung orban steht für einen
restriktiven kurs in der asylpolitik
mit der eu liegt ungarn da oft über
kreuz
und wer in ungarn die gesetze zur
asylpolitik in frage stellt ist
politisch auffällig
wer dazu nicht das eigene sondern das
höchste europäische gericht an fragt
ebenfalls
all das tat die junge richterin
gabriella szabo als sie den ogh fragte
ob das ungarische asylrecht
nichteuropäischen widersprechen
das ist der wahre grund meine ich für
meine absetzung dass ich den
europäischen gerichtshof um eine vorab
entscheidung über das so genannte stop
loss gesetz gebeten habe dass asylfragen
regelt
ich fragte den euro je ha bis gegen
europäisches recht verstößt
später bekam ich recht
es ist ein politisch heikles thema und
meine frage sorgte für missbilligung ich
meine das ist der grund aber ich kann
das schwer beweisen
die volle punktzahl hatte sie oft bei
sachlich fachlichen kriterien im
bewerbungsverfahren
gorilla ist eine fähige juristen von
2000 bewerbern und richterposten kam sie
auf rang 19 doch als publik wird dass
sie den eugh anrief explodierte das netz
sie zitiert auf deutsch
keiner schützte sie im gegenteil ihr
fall sollte abschrecken meint sie so
funktioniert das system aber
wir sollen nicht denken dass wir
unabhängig sind
geschichten wie meine sollen zum
nachdenken anregen und
mir fällt auf dass die richter sich
anpassen
hat dagegen geklagt dass sie als
richterin abgesetzt wurde sie ist nicht
die einzige die sagt das system setzte
sie unter druck die justiz ministerin
lehnt ein interview mit uns ab sicher
ist aber gesetze und regeln die hier
ausgearbeitet werden lassen ungarn jedes
jahr weiter im rechtsstaatlichkeit
ranking abrutschen auf nun rang 69
letzter platz unter den eu ländern
besonders bemängelt die eu das so eu
subventionen nicht ausreichend geschützt
sind vor korruption und missbrauch
siebenmal urteilte der bgh über ungarn
in rechtsstaatlichkeit verfahren immer
verlor ungarn
und deshalb darf die eu um überweisungen
an ungarn zurückhaltend bis sich die
rechtsstaatlichkeit bessert urteilten
die richter
[Musik]
sie führen jetzt einen heiligen krieg
einen rechtsstaatlichen jihad doch meine
freunde gegenüber den jihad helfen worte
selten hier müssen wir stärke zeigen
also komme die reconquista
der stopp der eu gelder ist ein harter
schlag für das system orban wenn die eu
das im ukraine krieg durchhält orban hat
es in den letzten zwölf jahren sehr
geschickt hinbekommen immer nicht das
dringlichste thema zu sein es gibt immer
andere größere krisen im moment ist es
die ukraine über jahre war er ist die
euro- und finanzkrise dann war es
migration anders praxis orban war nie
thema nummer eins und die anderen staats
und regierungschefs haben immer gesagt
wir gehen jetzt nicht gegen gegen orban
weil wir brauchen gerade geschlossenheit
das system bahn weiß krisen für sich zu
nutzen auch innenpolitisch kurz vor der
wahl drücken die ungarn hohe
benzinpreise
wir haben die politik der vier stopps
eingeführt stopp der nebenkosten
kraftstoff preisstopp zins stopp und
lebensmittel preisstopp
orban begrenzt die steigenden
benzinpreise ein wahlgeschenk für ihn
ist wichtig dass jeder von dieser
wohltat erfährt und dass sie niemand in
frage stellt dabei hilft ihm seine
einzigartige medienmacht
wie funktioniert das in der praxis eine
tankstelle in der provinz an der
zapfsäule steht bitte nicht tanken der
tankwart muss wegen orban benzin unter
dem einkaufspreis abgeben und fürchtet
nun um seine existenz
petkovic wurde deshalb am liebsten nur
noch bier verkaufen
ich kaufe den treibstoff teurer ein als
ich ihn verkaufen
meine reserven halten noch ein zwei
wochen das hängt davon ab wie viel jeder
tank
journalist balazs grimm von der
wochenzeitung magyar horn ist einer der
wenigen die hierüber berichten doch das
ist nicht so einfach
der kleine mann hat angst vor repression
und die großen männer auch zwei
bürgermeister haben sich geweigert
interviews zu geben die beiden sind von
der fidesz partei
viele halten inzwischen lieber den mund
an der tankstelle von herrn tolkewitz
jedoch hat er glück
soll ich tatsächlich meine meinung sagen
was die schmutzige regierung damit will
lieber nicht
der mistkerl soll abhauen orban ist ein
gemeiner dieb das ist meine meinung
[Musik]
die tankstellenbetreiber werden ruiniert
viele haben schon zugemacht
[Musik]
die regierungsnahe medien berichten zwar
das benzin jetzt billiger ist aber über
die konsequenzen davon reden sie nicht
kein wunder hier droht der innenminister
journalisten mit der polizei sollten sie
über die lage an den tankstellen nicht
so berichten wie orban sich das wünscht
in budapest besuche ich die redaktion
von herrn grimm die wochenzeitung
matterhorn viel geld haben sie nicht
aber dafür viel idealismus
das ist diese unabhängige wochenzeitung
gibt ist ein kleines wunder
ungefähr 90 prozent aller ungarischen
medien sind in der hand der
regierungspartei
aber möchte jede medienorganisation
beherrsche
lukas schreiber und seine kollegen haben
am eigenen leib erfahren wie orban
unliebsame zeitungen auf linie bringt
vor drei jahren war das als sie ihre
sachen packten da waren sie noch bei der
renommierten tageszeitung magyar nemzet
die war unabhängig 80 jahre lang dann
kaufte ein orban freund das blatt und
die unabhängigen journalisten gingen
ich war der unglückliche der damals den
abschieds artikel geschrieben
lukas hat nicht aufgegeben er gründete
ein neues blatt die matterhorn während
wir reden taucht plötzlich die
justizministerin im fernsehen auf es
geht um rechtsstaatlichkeit und die eu
die ministerin gibt eine pressekonferenz
da sehen sie die pressekonferenz der
regierung wir dürfen da nicht hin wir
durften keine fragen stellen und
bekommen
urbans kampf gegen die unabhängige
presse findet an allen fronten starr es
gibt nur noch orban freundliche
radiostationen das öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehen machte er zum staatspropaganda
sender ein fake news gesetz soll
fehlerhafte berichterstattung mit
gefängnis bestraft man weiß wer die
medien beherrscht hat die macht doch
dabei steht ihm noch ein großunternehmer
im wege
und das ist sollten burger der letzte
unabhängige medien mogul und eine der
reichsten ungarn
[Musik]
ich bin ein investor einer meiner
größten erfolge ich habe die
fluggesellschaft wizz air mit aufgebaut
ich liebe wettbewerb ich bin in vielen
bereichen aktiv elektrizität kabelnetze
bildung ich bin ein sehr glücklich
ihm gehört 24 punkte eine der
populärsten nachrichten webseiten in
ungarn nachdem ordensleute schon viele
redaktionen im ganzen land aufgekauft
hatten klopften sie auch bei war gar ein
[Musik]
ich habe immer wieder anrufe bekommen
willst du dich nicht auf einen kaffee
treffen und dann hieß es nebenbei ja ich
würde gerne deine redaktionen kaufen und
ich sage dann vielen dank aber die
stehen nicht zum verkauf
ich hatte immer wieder solche treffen am
ende des tages haben sie es dann
kapieren
viktor orban und seine regierung haben
verstanden sie brauchen die medien um an
der macht zu bleiben
sie können ihn nicht kaufen also haben
sie ihn abgehört und zwar mit der
pegasus software die eigentlich dafür
gedacht ist terroristen zu finden er
wurde beschattet und einer
schmierenkampagne ausgesetzt seine
redaktionen hat er trotzdem nicht
verkauft
aus meiner sicht sind die demokratie und
die freiheit nicht so stabil wie früher
aber nutzt alle mittel um an der macht
zu bleiben
dazu gehört auch unabhängige medien
finanziell auszutrocknen
lukasz kubot zeigt mir seufzend seine
zeitung fast keine werbeanzeigen kein
zufall
wir bekommen keine anzeigen von
internationalen unternehmen weil sie
geschäfte mit der regierung machen und
die wollen sie nicht aufs spiel setzt
ich hatte darüber eine sehr ehrliche
diskussion mit dem leiter einer grossen
deutschen autofirma in ungarn er sagte
mir dass sie eine neue fabrik in ungarn
eröffnen wollen dass die regierung dafür
hohe subventionen versprochen hat und
dass er nicht riskieren will dieses geld
zu verlieren
damit hört die schikane nicht auf die
matte johann kann nicht in ungarn
gedruckt werden das passiert im
nachbarland der slowakei
ungarische druckereien trauten sich
nicht mehr seine zeitung zu drucken sagt
luca job er vermutet sie fürchten organs
langen arm
[Musik]
wenn man ein guter unternehmer sein will
geht das nicht ohne kontakte zur
regierung
denn die regierung hat die macht den
firmen zu sagen du bist in unserer hand
und ich bestraft dich wenn ich
dies ist kein echter geldschein es ist
ein sinnbild das system orban hat sich
tief ins wirtschaftliche leben hinein
gefressen wer der fidesz partei
nahesteht gewinnt aufträge und geld sagt
unternehmer war gab es ist kein freier
markt erobern er eine freie
medienlandschaft oder eher eine wie bei
putin
wie bei putin
das system orban hat seinen preis
gabriella szabo hat vor gericht verloren
das urteil sie sei unfähig sie wird das
land wohl verlassen
erste und christina hoffen dass sie mit
ihrer familie in ungarn bleiben können
verleger lukac aber hofft weiter auf ein
zeigen deutsche autofirmen
[Musik]
peter marke weiter gegen die korruption
kämpfen
bürgermeister martha meint nach dem
krieg und nach der wahl wird alles hin
zu fuß
mit einem mann an der spitze auf den
alles ausgerichtet ist
viele posten der macht sind auf jahre
mit orban leuten besetzt völlig
unabhängig von den wahlen
ungarn first sagt ein starker mann und
das heißt vor allem orban fürs
[Applaus]